I have no name I'm just the default
never had a name it would be did not
expect a hit that you and I really did
with a domed Cena reference why am i
such an idiot are you sure about that
hello and welcome to PlayStation granade
it's time for some more shenanigans my
favorite game mode has been reintroduced
into follow what their hello I am joined
sit I've joined the squad lobby I'm
sorry how did you get your pick oh
listen to an Englishman talking to a
friend
Oh what how did you get your oh there he
is
where you going mate it's got a map
[Music]
you shall not pass
it's a season 8 pandemic it humps the
paws everywhere no one plays the game
everyone just sits in a bloody hamster
ball so freakin many I must protect the
six hamster balls in the last twelve
people who's that shooting these are my
hamster balls
I am the hamster ball herder if I see
someone trying to take my flock they
will die like you sir you I'm not one of
my hamster ball people be free my
pretties he's chasing me leave me alone
or am i chasing you around again over
the top look at this this is World Cup
quality this fight pickaxe me come on
pick ax fights do you agree to the
pickaxe fight I'm gonna fix this
hey you yeah what's he going for oh it's
gone for the trap play it's a strong
play against a new book with the pickaxe
this is gonna be a very hard kill for
him how always close his gloves the
pickaxe news is coming come on
he must be our eyes use the rift against
the new bin pickaxes monster this
there's more come on come on all right
this is taking forever just you've taken
all the fun out of this I just wanted
one pickaxe pal but no but no no and now
look at you you did pickaxe battles hey
still like the girl who shot that bullet
I don't know what's going on
who's shooting these things
I look at that guy's Eddie in a window
oh I love this game from the window to
the wall to the sweat drips up my buff
hamster balls what's your opinion on
them I'm not sure
never you gotta kill them this guy seems
quite hey I still hate hamster balls if
you use them I hate you too
if I can see it if I just believe it
there's nothing to it
that would have been good too oh well
maybe next hey redeemed myself I believe
one two three four of you you're all
going down I am on fire today you're
gonna - wish your flower we'll get em
next time let me take that again
there we go - left dreadful dreadful any
shots if you here we go okay easy shots
we will hit hard shots
there we go that's back to normal I feel
good again last guy I were I in last guy
I don't think he's got a clue
this is having a nice day oh please
check that back
I am certain that that was a nutmeg it
went straight through his legs tickle
his boat on the way through
he's legit just gonna stay there really
this is the last fight really really
really this is why I never show the
final kill because it's always terrible
no I know the Georges rush you know
anything is you've got a hit right
instead of wanting one shot game mode
all right that went really well but
usually it's not that easy
shooting works
I still hate bushes either bush kill the
bush by eating a bush in the middle of
the bush I've never done that before
supposedly though if you can hit them
into ports it's an insta-kill
I've never done it before yes I have
come on you know
I bet that's live it like everybody else
it oh there's a fight I like third
parties we left the third party we like
we like to third party are you hiding
behind the tree Jesus Christ that's
Jason Bourne stealth.stealth is my
middle name
gunshots I'm the sky you bloody tree is
this guy you did you did oh I'll be
latched in the groin
get up migraine no suction don't finish
that joke in a bush I think he's trying
to kill me with the we're gonna try and
knock him out with his own needs with
your own Nate we like to party we like
we like to party we like to party hello
brother
it's okay you've got nothing to fear why
can't we be friends why can't we be
friends why I don't think this guy's oh
he hasn't gonna what don't worry fella
you've got nothing to worry about I'm
not gonna give you a weapon and I'll
give you abilities to get away from
people so yours I'll be friends
Nicky look at that's a good Bush dude
have a nice day
I do I want to shoot you if you don't
come away and don't worry how are you
okay I can't even get my shots anyway go
die a nice gentle star most gentle start
make a solid wall and just a quick quick
short turnaround killed a guy who's up
there and that's pretty nice pretty nice
story top mary got him partner and you
kiss CC whatever you call we're gonna
win this bro
two down stick together no I didn't
bloody window rain to me
how you doing 90 Kim keep it together
fellow we're gonna win this mannequin
where's the other people it's too over
there you can't hear me I don't know I'm
say intruder alert what else
I think we may be the best team ever
Heineken woo with that from the tree
should be what a clever play one day
Heineken to say something to me it'll be
sweet I must avenge my brother Heineken
oh he was sniped oh I'm terrible at this
absolutely terrible worst player in the
lobby but y'all stop still see you
actually may be worse than me geez bro
Heineken keep with me dude give me
advice
I advise it was just a squeak noise oh
oh I'm in the French Lobby but I don't
know that means I need to impress
impress this French people come on guys
what you doing presents to the gold I'll
try it I'll try it I'll try it I don't
know what I guess that has to anguish
best oh that's German oh yeah you know I
did a good languages but until I butcher
it yay bah Levon francais la piscine
splish splosh hey you made it to the end
of another one of these videos thank you
very much I do appreciate you staying
till the end anyway we always finish
with a bit of a dance from the people
who are kind enough to use my code a
damaru in the fortnight shop
these guys make this weekly video
possible and I appreciate you massively
thank you very much if you want to be on
screen with these guys simply take a
photo if you use my code in the
fortnight shop and you can be one of
these leggings here anyway thank you
very much for your time in the comments
this week I'll be looking for people
telling bad dad jokes I need some bad
dad joke so if you can do that I will
definitely give you a heart anyway
thanks for your time hopefully I'll see
you again next time
I'm Adam from Playstation grenades and
this was our unprofessional Saturday
[Music]